hello and welcome to this Intelligence
Squared online debate uh we should all
go vegan and I can say that I have been
both vegan and
carnivore I would say on West and I've
also been vegetarian I've tried the
whole lot I'm pescetarian
um but I am very open to debate
um and to my mind being changed so first
of all I'm going to ask you to make your
first vote so we can see whether your
mind's going to be changed
um you need to vote for or against the
motion should we all go vegan and if
you're unsure you can vote undecided
this is going to take a couple of
minutes probably for the results to come
through so before we start I'm going to
explain briefly how this session is
going to work
in a moment our two Debaters are going
to make their opening speeches then I'm
going to chess and debate between the
two of them and then I'm going to take
your questions so anything you think of
as you go along uh you need to scribble
down and then you can send it across and
at 6 55 the speakers are going to end
the debate with short closing statements
and then I'm going to ask you all to
vote again we're going to see whether
anyone has changed their mind at all
so if you can start sending your
questions to the speakers as soon as you
uh want and you can type your question
in the box at the bottom of the screen
and if you don't want your name
mentioned don't worry you can just click
anonymous
before you press send you can also tweet
using the hashtag iq2 and uh then we
will see what the first vote is and I
haven't actually seen it yet
I haven't been told what it is so we may
have to start before we know what the
answer is
unless anyone else as George have you
been given the results before me
I resent them in the post yesterday yeah
exactly so I think then we should get
going and I will if the results come
through I will and
I think we should first I'm going to
give a brief instruction to George who
doesn't really need very much
introduction he's a guardian columnist
he's the best-selling author whose
latest book is Regenesis feeding the
world without devouring the planet which
is uh fantastic read and very eloquent
as well as persuasive he's a committed
vegan
um although I think occasionally you
have cracked and you can watch his
documentary it's apocalypse cow how meat
killed the planet which is on channels
for my four
and I think actually you may have eaten
a stag in that
um although it was shot entirely for
environmental reasons
um but I'm sure hope it wasn't that
yeah well the answers don't you could
actually have the answers on toast can't
you can you yes isn't that what lady
laying down did
um I came here to learn stuff and this
already begun let me try it out one time
on X more Dartmouth
um George is going to speak for seven
minutes so would you like to start now
thanks Alice well yeah the the problem
we have with this debate is that the
great majority of people I think it's
fair to say are in deep denial about
where their animal products come from
and we all uh have a picture of
livestock farming um as being the
picture that was really planted in our
minds by those children's books that we
were all exposed to when we were
pre-literate you know the the classic
children's book is a livestock farm with
one rosy cute farmer one cow one Pig one
horse one one cat one chicken they all
talk to each other they all live in
harmony no indication of why they might
be there or where they might be going
and the reality could not be further
from the truth as I found when I worked
on an intensive pig farm as a teenager
and every day I was thinking first of
all this isn't what they told me farming
was about and secondly why is this legal
you know if we treated our cats and dogs
like we treat pigs and chickens for
example we would be sent to prison
but the great majority of our animal
products come from intensive factory
farms like that um in countries like the
UK between about 85 and 90 of our animal
products come from those places and they
are devastating for Animal Welfare but
also environmentally devastating
um and that's because they need to be
fed they can't feed themselves in those
sheds and so the food is imported often
from the other side of the world where
it can be have devastating consequences
in its production area the size of Spain
in Brazil has been destroyed to produce
soy
um to largely to feed the world's farm
animals
um and and then the nutrients pass
through those animals there's far too
much done for the land to absorb and so
when Farmers spread it on the land they
claim they're fertilizing it in fact
they're dumping the dung it washes off
into the rivers and kills the rivers and
we're seeing this with The River Why
many other rivers around the Welsh
borders
um dairy farms are doing Sim in
Patrick's part of the world
pembrokeshire and and in my part of the
world in Devon as well with just
horrendous consequences and so people
say well the answer then obviously is to
go for extensive livestock farming free
range livestock farming and to eat
pasture-fed meat and this has become the
great call of Foodies and celebrity
chefs and even some environmentalists
that's the answer because you know we
like that picture we like the picture of
cattle and sheep grazing in the fields
it looks harmonious it chimes with
thousands of years of pastoral poetry
and children's stories
um and you know BBC programs because if
the BBC were any Kino and sheep it would
be illegal
um but the reality of that is in some
ways even worse than the reality of
factory farming because of the vast
amount of a resource that it uses that
we neglect massively in environmental
discussions it's possibly the most
important of all metrics and yet we
scarcely discuss it it should be right
up there with greenhouse gases synthetic
chemicals all the rest of it what is it
land use the amount of land we use is an
absolutely critical environmental issue
because every hectare we use for our own
extractive purposes is a hectare which
can't be used to support wild ecosystems
so such as forests and wetlands and
Savannahs and natural grasslands not not
enclosed and used for pasture and and
those wild ecosystems are what the great
majority of the world species depend on
and in fact Earth Systems as a whole
depend on the survival of wild
ecosystems now there's one area in which
we are tuned into land use and that
would that's when it comes to urban
sprawl and we all dislike urban sprawl
and so we should it's bad for cities
it's bad for the countryside but the
entire urban area of the planet occupies
one percent of its land surface all the
homes all the businesses all the
infrastructure one percent much of the
rest of the planet is Desert is ice caps
is is mountain ranges
um just 15 is protected areas but by Far
and Away the greatest land use is
farming and um and farming occupies
roughly 38 of the land surface of the
planet and when I say farming you're
probably thinking of growing crops but
that occupies just 12 of the land
surface of the planet and of that almost
half those crops are being grown to feed
to those animals in the factory farms so
only six or seven percent of the
planet's surface is growing crops to
feed humans directly so what about the
26 percent of lamb which makes up that
all that is producing pasture-fed
animals it's basically pasture-fed meat
production and this carries an enormous
ecological opportunity cost and an
enormous carbon opportunity cost in
other words the cost of what you're not
using that land for which is supporting
wild ecosystems and despite the
outrageous climate denial claims of the
livestock industry
wild ecosystems are almost invariably
much richer in carbon
um and and lowering greenhouse gas
emissions
um than any of the pastures being used
to produce our beef or our lamb now
there was a study in the United States
which said what if we were to do what
all the food is in celebrity chefs are
doing and switch away from eating
corn-fed beef which is enough of a
problem and switch towards pasture-fed
beef they found that you would have to
increase the area used to produce cattle
in the United States by 270 percent
you'd have to cut down all the forests
drain all the wetlands water all the
deserts Diggers at the national parks
demolish the cities and you would still
be importing a lot of your beef from
Brazil that's simply not enough planet
to do it we could all eat pasture fed
beef and and laugh if we had several
planets and no space for wild ecosystems
on any of them but as we don't and as we
desperately need to conserve and restore
wild ecosystems if we're going to get
through this Century we just can't gate
that right to ourselves
um and and the fact is that you know if
we were to make that switch to pasture
fed beef only the rich would eat it you
know there's this idea where we can all
eat less and better but that you know
does that ever work with any luxury
product you know do do do the world's
poor eat Beluga caviar once a year
um or bluefin tuna sushi once a year no
because that's not how luxury products
are distributed if we produced far less
meat which we ought to only the very
rich would eat it there is no good way
of providing animal products which
everyone can meet eat without inflicting
enormous damage to Earth Systems
and so we we live in this state of
delusion really that that we can somehow
have a thriving planet and at the same
time
um eat exactly what we want to eat but
actually our diets are by far and away
the biggest impact of all the things we
do and by far the biggest component of
that impact is eating livestock products
in fact if we if we stopped eating
livestock products according to a paper
in science uh we would save 76 of the
agricultural land area that we currently
use and if we did that then that would
enable a great Global rewilding we could
restore ecosystems on a massive scale we
could bring back the rainforest we could
bring back the wetlands we could bring
back the Wild savannas and the wild
grasslands at Sea we could bring back
the the celt forest the coral reefs the
ocean uh the ocean sea floor which is
absolutely essential to protect in life
and protecting carbon and all that would
be possible if we switched away from an
animal-based diet to a plant-based diet
and I don't think this is a luxury in
fact it's quite hard to see how we're
going to avoid the sixth great
Extinction and for that matter the
collapse of Earth Systems unless we
switch away from eating animals there
are two fundamental things that we have
to do to prevent the the environmental
disaster that scientists predict if we
don't change course one is to leave
fossil fuels in the ground the other is
to stop eating animals thank you
fantastic now I have to say the results
are in so you've got quite an uphill
battle I feel George but it was very uh
well argued so we'll Welcome to my life
but eight percent agree and 48 disagree
um with 44 undecided
so I think we're now over to Patrick
um who may have an easier job but on the
other hand if you lose some voters
um it may be awkward so we will talk now
to you and you are the founder and chief
executive of the sustainable food trust
and Patron of the UK biodynamic
Association and
um I think really since I first became
interested in farming you have been a
major player on the scene and very
involved
I think the first time I met was bread
making actually so you've been involved
in the whole process for Generations
really
um your work centers on the importance
of transforming our food and farming
systems to address climate change and
Traverse the biodiversity loss and
improve Public Health
uh you're also an organic farmer in
Wales and you've got a herd of Atia cows
so George may not be thrilled by that
but your milk goes to produce cheese and
um you are
feeding
um people not with a vegan diet but with
a much more healthy diet that they might
get if they just popped down to
McDonald's so you now have seven minutes
to speak
well thank you very much
um thank you George and I just would
like to start by acknowledging your
great work George I think you are an
incredible environmentalist and
campaigner I've admired you for many
years and I think your book regeneres
this uh the first half of which I fully
agree with is a brilliant critique of
what is wrong uh with industrial farming
including livestock so there is so much
we share and for me it's very
disappointing uh that there's such a
polarization of our views over the role
of livestock in sustainable farming
systems because I agree with you that
the Livestock systems that predominate
all over the world at the moment are
definitely part of the problem but
rather than trade statistics with you
which we could do and no doubt we will
do it when I've had my six minutes and
there's a bit of a you know back and
forward I want to talk about my own
practical experience and because I think
that one of the reasons why I think you
doubt the capacity of farming to
transport in a way which will have
livestock really at the center of the
sustainable Food Systems which replace
the ones we've got at the moment is
because you're not a practitioner I am a
practitioner I'm within a month of
celebrating our 50th Anniversary here on
this 300 acre mainly livestock Farm you
know that we've grown vegetables along
the road and we were just talking about
it we used to be a carrot producer for
supermarkets we had to stop because the
system got too centralized and I've just
been out today ridging up my potatoes so
I'm a a definitely a vegetable grower
but the main use of the land on this
Farm uh is for producing uh livestock we
have now a 90 car air shahead and
followers
and we produce cheese as Alice just said
and what is really interesting about our
farm after 50 years of not using any
nitrogen fertilizer and farming in
harmony with nature is the impacts the
first of which I want to focus on a
little bit which is carbon we just had a
carbon ordered and it looks as though if
you believe the data that we are
actually carbon negative in other words
the soil building of in the permanent
pasture and the rotations because we do
gross emotes and peas to feed our cows
looks as if it not only offsets the
methane emission of the cows but also
the energy that we use on the farm so we
are net carbon negative now obviously
this is just one farm and I I also want
to speak about the nature impacts uh you
said that if we took more land out of
production to
um if we if we carried on
um if we went to my system at scale it
would have devastating impacts because
we'd have to have more land in
production well the if you farm in
harmony with nature you have fantastic
biodiversity outcomes our farm is alive
with birds small mammals insects
amphibians all because we're not farming
in a hostile way and the like the
wildlife can coexist with the system we
also employ around seven full-time
equivalent labor units on the farm and
so if you take it together
we are producing a lot of food we're
producing enough cheese to feed 3 000
people uh the milk we sell could feed
another two and a half thousand and the
meat which comes either from the dairy
cows at the end of their lives or the
male carbs can feed another 500. now you
might say this is just one farm and what
did you say you said we're living in a
state of delusion well I I plead guilty
I am in the state of delusion after 50
years I'm convinced that my farming
system could go to scale and if you
don't believe me we did a report which
we published just recently called
feeding Britain from the ground up where
we modeled a nationwide transition of
farming to sustainable farming systems
operating within planetary boundaries
the sort of farming I'm doing here we
looked at the impact on total food
output and the fascinating conclusions
are that we could maintain and maybe
even slightly increase our national
level of food security and our staple
foods if we switched to farming systems
like the one we are using here and if we
scale that globally yes we could feed
the world but only if we ate differently
here's some areas where we agree we'd
give up all industrial livestock farming
no more cheap chicken no more horrible
pork from industrial pork units or Mega
dairies you mentioned there are Mega
dairies near this Farm in karadigian but
if we
if we gave up eating meat it would be a
problem because the Farms that need the
farming systems that need to replace the
ones we've got at the moment would rely
on a rotation 50 of which at any one
time would be infertility building and
that would normally be Clover and grass
and to maximize the food output from
that system and actually I would say to
revitalize the soil we need livestock
grazing livestock yes mainly grass-fed
not exclusively grass-fed at a dairy
system but certainly with beef and lamb
production more or less 100 grass-fed
and if we did that we'd actually have
quite a lot of meat to eat but far more
than most people think what we have to
give up is the cheap chicken that
everybody's become used to so in summary
I'm not sure how I'm doing for time but
in summary if that system was scaled
globally every country would have a
different diet because obviously the
geography soils and climate of different
countries varies but there's no reason
why we couldn't maintain our livestock
production except that we've changed
what we eat and take that to scale so I
think that you need to come here George
you remember you may remember you were
here in 2007 at the launch of transition
Town Lampeter but you didn't have a
chance to do around but uh in
celebration of our 50th Anniversary come
and look for yourself because I think at
this time it's important that
environmental environmentalists work
together sync our differences and share
our stories and my story is that it is
possible to produce livestock working in
harmony with nature my wife uh Becky is
out there milking the cows at the moment
she sings to them when when when she's
milking they are loved they are treated
with compassion throughout their whole
lives and the cheese and the milk that
we produce and the meat is a reflection
of our compassion for the animals
there's no reason why we can't take that
to scale
thank you George now is there any more
questions they're coming in now but we
we can take quite a few more um I'm
going to start I'm very interested
Patrick today you're on the Today
program but and you weren't invited to
number 10 but you really should have
been shouldn't you buy for the farming
conference today do you think uh
listening to what came out of that the
government has any interest at all in
your kind of farming and being more
sustainable or do you think in the end
we're more worried about trade Wars and
about trying to be profitable
I think well I think trade Wars are
important because we need to have a way
of measuring the sustainable impact of
all the different foods that we're
trading in because trade will continue
because we are structurally unable to be
self-sufficient but I don't think that
the sort of issues that I was talking
about on the Today program this morning
will have featured in the conversation
when we when I listened to Judith
Bachelor and Minette batters later on in
the program I was thoroughly depressed
and it was rather annoying that the
presenters didn't bring up the points
that I'd made because it seems to me
that we need an agricultural transition
just like we've had or are having an
energy transition and it will have many
of the same features because at the
moment if you farm in a sustainable way
as we do you make less money and a less
profitable than if you're farming in an
extractive way when I'm sure George and
I would agree with that so what we need
is a mechanism like the feed-in tariffs
to enable the transition to truly
sustainable farming systems which do
involve would involve rotations to build
fertility and I think that's the key
point that we need to drill down on
because I don't think Tully um is a
Great Hero in uh George's book Regenesis
I've known Tony for 40 years he's a
vegan grower he said to me very recently
quote you know I agree with you about
the role of livestock in extensive
farming systems definitely you can
produce vegetables
um in a vegan system tolly does it and
my friend Peter Sega down the road does
it but if you want to farm at scale you
need a crop rotation and to turn that
crop rotation into food that we can eat
uh we need grazing livestock
so George what is wrong with um
Patrick's assessment that you had lots
of small farms that were carbon negative
and that were produced at scale why we
couldn't accept that and have that
wouldn't that actually be a better way
of producing a sustainable environment
sustainable farming well I don't want to
dis um what Patrick does at all you know
he's he's totally insincere and you know
he's a lovely Guy and um he treats his
cows very well and all the rest of it
but I just don't buy it if he is indeed
a carbon negative livestock Farm he's
the first one on earth because there's
been endless studies pure published in
peer-reviewed journals looking at the
claims of being carbon negative and none
of them so far have withstood the
scientific Pro process in fact there was
a meta study published at the Oxford
Martin School part of Oxford University
called grazed and Confused looked at 300
papers and it found no instance anywhere
on Earth of livestock Farmers even
washing their own faces in terms of
greenhouse gas emissions let alone
lowering down extra carbon emissions and
there's a fantastic amount and not in
any way saying that this is what
Patrick's doing because but you know
there is a huge amount of jiggery pokery
involved in in carbon calculations of
what's going on under the soil and it's
just
far too easy to make things look right
when they really aren't
as for the idea of well we could produce
more pasture fed me I mean already 51 of
the UK is is producing pasture-fed meat
and yet it produces scarcely any I did
calculations for for sheep for Martin
and lamb and estimated that 4 million
hectares of the Uplands are being used
to produce mutton and lamb in this
country and yet it produces just one
percent of our diet now four million
hectares is the same amount of as all
the grain growing in in in in the UK
which produces a very substantial part
of our diet it's a really profligate
form of land use it's agricultural
sprawl is what we're looking at and this
has an enormous opportunity cost so if
you look at the hills of Britain they
are almost entirely bare there's
scarcely any trees above 200 meters
parts of inner London have more trees
per hectare than those Hills have
including in our national parks and
people think that's natural it's not the
altitudinal tree line in the UK is is
well over a thousand meters everywhere
except perhaps the top of the kangoms
and one or two other very Rocky parts of
the Highlands almost everywhere else
there would be trees in the western half
of Britain it would be dominated by
temperate rainforests the reason there
are no trees is primarily because sheep
and cattle selectively browse out tree
seedlings they're extremely nutritious
they're the things they like to eat more
than anything else and so unless you
bring your numbers down to ridiculously
low levels one sheet per 20 hectares no
trees are going to grow and that is the
most basic component of ecological
regeneration trees returning to a
formerly forested landscape you haven't
got trees returning it's not
regeneration it's not Regen narrative
um and so you get all these terms banded
around this is regenerative farming you
know it's just like the word sustainable
it gets just tacked on to anything you
happen to be doing regenerative ranching
formerly known as ranching
um it's just just a word which people
use and when you look at the actual
wildlife which Farms even wonderful
beautiful picture book Farms like
Patrick's support it's a very thin
selection of the wildlife that could
otherwise be living there starting with
the large Predators you know we don't
have wolves and links in this country
because livestock Farmers insist that
they don't get reintroduced having wiped
them out because they um compete with us
for for food which is because they might
eat some of the livestock and everywhere
you go on Earth with only one or two
very small exceptions large predators
are driven
um to Extinction or to the brink of
Extinction at the behest of livestock
Farmers you don't have the trees growing
on these farms uh there was a another
meta-analysis looking at a hundred
papers
um and found out that for all major
ecological groups Guilds of of Wildlife
um every single one suffers from having
Livestock on the land except for
detritophores animals which he'd done
all the other groups suffer they all
improve when you take the livestock off
the land so this idea that you can
square the circle you know we can have
our beautiful picture of the cattle and
the Sheep grazing on the land and you
can have thriving ecosystems it exists
in picture books it exists in in our
image of farming but actually what the
numbers show is something very different
and and you know Patrick he paints a
beautiful picture but the problem is we
are dealing in pictures when we
desperately need to be dealing in
numbers we need to become food numerate
and just as with climate issues you know
we've slowly become climate numerate
we've begun to do the maths we've begun
to understand how much fossil fuels we
need to leave in the ground if we were
to avoid a certain amount of global
heating the same has to happen with food
otherwise we're cooked
definitely reply in a minute but they've
asked whether when you scale up your
system
um would people be able to eat the same
amount of me are you expecting to them
to have the same sort of diet or if you
had your Farms rolled out across the
countryside would they be eating a
predominantly vegetable based diet with
some of your cheese and sustainable uh
the I mean the answer is all in our
report feeding Britain from the ground
up I would recommend people should
download it from our website
um and there's a lot of data in there
and it's all very carefully researched
and if I'm unable to trade statistics
with George now I've got colleagues
Robert Barber Richard young back at base
camp who will do that because we care as
much as George does about getting the
data right so George raised a lot of
issues
um evidence of soil carbon outcomes
that's important very important the
French Minister Stefan lafoll at the cop
21 set a target of four per thousand
catch per meal uh it was a challenge for
all the countries of the world to use
farming systems which built their soil
carbon by point four percent per year
now I'm sure George doubts uh the
veracity of our recent audit and that's
fair enough George but there's a growing
body of evidence that shows that if you
adopt holistic grazing practices as we
have been doing here for the last five
years you get a continuous soil carbon
gain and the most surprising thing about
our recent audit was because we've been
keeping soil carbon records for now over
10 years is that some of the permanent
pastures which have been now
rotationally grazed with a mob grazing
system was showing the highest soil
carbon gain now obviously one swallow
doesn't make a summer and that's it so
it's a very important thing to test but
there is a website called carbon Cowboys
run by a man called Peter Bick who's a
researcher at the University of Arizona
State Arizona Arizona State University
who's been doing some really amazing
work on comparing holistic grazing Farms
with their neighbors and it looks as
though those Farms could achieve the
four per thousand Target as set by at
the cop 21. I think think we may be
getting close to it here so it's really
important that we we do more research in
this area there's a growing body of
research suggesting that you can build
soil carbon really quite quickly and if
we're right then that's huge and I'm
sure George you would agree that if this
evidence can be presented to you and you
thought it was valid you would have to
change your opinion about livestock well
that's always the case with with
everything if if I see the evidence I
will change my opinion you know I'm
entirely evidence-led on this issue
which is why I turn from being an
advocate of meat eating to a vegan can I
just say George that's fantastic because
I I think this is the beginning of a
conversation between us where we really
do need to look hard at the data and by
the way I hope you'll know a chap called
Pete Smith who's a grassland scientist
at the University of Aberdeen and he's
more with you and than with me about the
potential of grassland to build soil
carbon but I said to him when I recently
saw him you know absence of evidence
isn't necessarily evidence of absence
sure and the truth is the grassland
science Community have not been doing
proper studies on this but we don't have
an absence of evidence on this um in
fact um it's it's really very clear
you're quite right that some forms of
ranching will sequester more carbon than
other forms of ranching but not by
comparison to the Natural ecosystems
that would have been there before though
you know you can offset finishes so so
you can say okay in this field where
there are X number of cows grades in a
particular way there's more carbon than
in this field where their y number of
cows grades in a different way yeah
that's totally a fine and and we can we
can agree on that but what what the the
climate change committee the government
statutory climate change committee shows
is that if you go from pasture
to Woodland which is what what much of
the land we're talking about would have
supported you increase your carbon by 25
tons per hectare that's just your below
ground carbon let alone the carbon in
the trees above ground and this is
massively greater than any of the sort
of details but this this grazing system
versus that grazing system
absolutely George I just want to say I
don't think that's true you don't think
that what the CCC is true no I don't and
by the way Lord dieben who's the chair
of the climate change committee
privately agrees with me yeah you see
you're giving yourself a private
anecdote you know someone said to me
this someone said you know the the
published figures Patrick are you know
that that had you we have to meet
certain scientific standards I know that
if we're to to so I'm just going to move
on but I think that we've also got on
your side you really need to um explain
what you're what you want instead so
someone's put what are the true costs of
producing healthy vegan-based products
and the new scientists this week
suggested that lab grow meat could be 25
times worse for the climate than beef
sure so I mean I'm not happy yeah so my
problem was I read your book and and I
thought the first half was extraordinary
I loved it I thought it was really tough
brilliant and then when you started
getting on to
um talking about you know meat grown in
factories and taking pills I sort of
lost the plot because I felt like
talking about taking pills honestly it's
the sense that it didn't feel natural to
me anymore
1930s sci-fi epic well it felt like that
very much when you wrote it and I think
when you talk about it we're not going
to be able to eat the links we're not
going to want to eat the Beavers what
what are you expecting people to eat are
they just going to be eating props but
then also we will have then grown the
crops on land so that's not all going to
be Woodland is it no so well for I mean
if you were to do what I broadly do
which is to eat a large plant-based diet
you would immediately greatly reduce
your land footprint your greenhouse gas
footprint your water footprint just
about everything which is involved in in
producing our our food you reduce those
Footprints but and that's you know just
where we are using plants as our
substitutes now plants aren't great
substitutes for animal products you know
and and if you're not going to eat
substitute animal products and I'm not
remotely interested in Veggie sausages
or or veggie burgers I don't I don't
really like them I don't think they're
very good yeah I prefer just to eat
um nice plant-based meals there's lots
of brilliant Indian meals and Thai meals
and loads of wonderful things you can
make entirely with plants which aren't
pretending to be animal products but I
realize that I'm in the minority here
you know most people are going to want
to eat something very much like animal
products now for 12 000 years
we've been farming multilateral
multi-cellular organisms plants and
animals and we pretty well push them to
the absolute limits of their efficiency
I mean I think you can say with a
chicken you push it beyond the limits
they can't even support their own weight
anymore many of the chickens that people
eat but we've scarcely begun to explore
the farming of unicellular organisms and
I think this is going to be a massive
shift in human diet
um and indeed in human civilization
itself it's going to be the most
important
um environmental technology ever
developed because if we do switch to to
farming microbes instead of farming
markets
we can greatly beg your pun
I said I'm farming microbes
that's well of course of course that's
right but but that's a highly
inefficient way of doing it
just finished what I'm saying and then
you can come onto your lovely cows but
you know so so
growing microbes I mean you know on for
instance if you use hydrogen or methanol
as your feedstock you can reduce the
land area by thousands of times you can
reduce your water use massively your
fertilizer use massively according to my
calculations
all the world's protein in an area the
size of greater London not that I'm
suggesting that that we grow it there
but that would enable a massive
rewilding and those and and by producing
unicellular organisms you can produce
far better substitutes for animal
products than you Cannery plants but
also I think it'll trigger a whole new
Cuisine because just as the first people
to domesticate a wild cow weren't
thinking about Camembert there's a huge
range of potential products that we can
start making from microbes now I know
this all sounds very sci-fi but it's not
about pills I mean I the first I was the
first person outside the lab to eat a
pancake made entirely from bacteria it's
delicious tasted just like a pancake
it's but but we've got to start think
looking big and at the moment we're in a
situation with livestock where we're
saying to people oh just stop eating it
but we're not giving you any good
substitutes it's a bit like saying stop
burning fossil fuels but we don't have
solar panels or windmills so what are
you going to do just just get cold so so
it we now have the potential and I think
we should stop feeling afraid of it we
should stop being so neophobic we should
grasp the enormous scope for greatly
reducing the environmental impacts of
our diets so Ewan has put here without
life celebrity return nutrients and
organic matter to soils that are used to
Growing grains so how does Patrick would
say how how are you going to restore
those soils that have been growing
grains yeah well there's there's a huge
amount of amount of Mythology around
this you know people say well we're
mimicking nature this is the way you do
it when you look at mixed farming yields
they're really small by comparison to
other forms of grain growing or
vegetable and fruit growing and so that
it leads to
considerable agricultural sprawl it
means you have to use more land to
produce a given amount of food George
and then when you look up the use of
manure as a fertilizer you find you're
losing 37 more nitrogen than you do with
artificial fertilizers which is why the
soil Association rules allow you to
import manure from conventional Farms
using Harbor Bosch nitrogen but at one
step removed
George I on this Farm
we are practicing farming and harmony
with nature and the results are
fantastic for carbon for nature for
people and for good delicious food come
and see and walk around the farm with me
because honestly This Is 50 years of
practice our yields are going up there
they're not tiny yields we're growing
crops in a rotation and to the point
that Alice made if you're going to
rebuild the devitalites and decarbonize
soils after 60 or 70 years of continuous
arable farming you need a crop rotation
and typically 50 of that rotation will
be fertility building of clover and
grass and in order to turn that bit of
the rotation into food that we can eat
then you need ruminant animals and I am
certain from my own observation here
that the system works and builds
fertility of soil and the methane
emission of the rumors which have been
part of an ancient carbon cycle can be
more than an offset by the soil carbon
gain I'm really confident about this
I've never felt more positive about our
relationship with nature which of which
we are part and the animals that part
and even in your wild ecosystems you're
going to have deer you're going to have
and we're the top predator and unless
you have nails and many lynxes and you
know you're going to have to control
some of these animals and I agree with
you about sheep of course there are too
many sheep on the mountains there's so
much inspiration that can be found from
a growing number of farmers all over the
world but including in the UK who are
adopting these regenerative systems I
agree with you there's no formal
definition but I'm talking about a
serious definition as we use in our
feeding written report to define the
practices I really think you should
reassess your view about the the
efficiency in ecological terms of the
farming systems that I've been using for
50 years
just come back briefly on this you know
when you look at the numbers you find
that in order to produce something which
is in any way ecologically regenerative
in other words for instance that the net
wildlands as a state in Sussex very
famous
a lot of people say you know this
reconciles
um um The Return of wildlife with food
production and it is a great example of
what you call non-trophic rebuilding
rewilding without Predators you know so
it's missing some components but there's
a lot coming back and it's brilliant but
they produce 54 kilos of meat per
hectare per year and if you were to turn
the whole of Britain internet you would
we would each have 75
um calories of meat per day and nothing
else it's tiny tiny productivity
well well actually I have read that
report and it's so full of holes it
makes a calendar look look watertight
but anyway please can we can we trade
with a public exchange of emails
starting now your critique of feeding
Britain because we put a lot I'd be
happy to do that but I think I'm going
to move on now because otherwise I'm
just going to be trading facts and
figures and disagreeing with each other
so uh Joe has actually put a very
question which isn't the vegan versus
Omni more vulnerable argument a
distraction from the bigger causes of
environmental damage from transport and
energy and plastic you know actually if
you take someone like Patrick's Farm
what he's doing could actually be
beneficial
um and it could be neutral you feel it
that actually maybe mildly detrimental
but it's nothing like flying or the
plastic waste or um really just human
consumption of goods that goes on
outside food production
well actually
um livestock production produces more
greenhouse gas emissions than All
Transport
um that there's a recent paper showing
um it's uh I mean there's a range we
can't be completely sure but at the
lower part of the lower point of the
range is still higher than that
you've got it might be um it depends I
mean if you were to roll that out
um because of the methane and nitrous
oxide produced by by his cattle
um and you know he you know he makes
these claims about soil carbon well
we'll see but but because of those very
powerful greenhouse gases
um uh it could even be under Patrick
system that that would continue we need
to specifically if we were eating all
your pancakes George wouldn't that would
also be detrimental wouldn't it because
we'd be having farming and factories and
we would also it would probably be done
to scale and you would also get these
you know bath conglomerates so and it
may not actually be particularly
nutritious for people to eat either well
you've mixed up about six different
issues in one question there so it makes
it rather hard to answer but if you're
talking about greenhouse gas emissions
much much lower from Precision
fermentation than than than from any of
the farming systems we're talking about
um yes there's a real danger of
corporate concentration as there is in
all aspects of the food system and
indeed all aspects of the commercial
system and so as as everywhere antitrust
laws should be strong and intellectual
property rights should be weak and that
requires political campaigning but at
the moment 90 of the global grain trade
is in the hands of four corporations do
we ban the global grain trade well if we
did billions would start no we've got to
break up those corporations and we need
to do that in the new food economy just
as we need to do that in the old food
economy
and you think you could do that
well I mean look it's within the human
capacity to create political change but
it doesn't happen passively we have to
get together we have to campaign we have
to mobilize to create the food system as
well as all other aspects of the
economic system that we want to see but
that only comes about effectively
through political action it's not going
to come about through consumerism alone
and we've become really passive when it
comes to political action you know we
allow the big corporations to walk all
over us and that's that's a change it
didn't used to be like that antitrust
laws used to be strong intellectual
property rights used to be weak but it's
been reversed by the effectiveness of
corporate lobbying and the
ineffectiveness of citizens campaigning
but just say we took Patrick's view
um and Nick sinfield's asked this
um how long would it take to rapidly
translate that to a level of success
across the countryside what kind of
measures would you need because
at the same time I mean both of them
they're both are actually not at
extremes but they're they're both very
different views it really depends on how
they're rolled out both of them doesn't
it so it does depend on big business it
does depend on that how how could yours
be rolled out Patrick to make it work I
do think it would need a large companies
I think it'll need a large retailers I
think it's a top-down and bottom-up
transition and it will need a bit like
as I mentioned the energy transition
um that started with the the then German
minister of Agriculture Renata kunas to
introducing the freedom tariffs which
essentially taxed the fossil fuel
companies uh to enable a small-scale
renewable energy generation to be
profitable and look where we've got to
now it's more profitable to produce
using renewable energy than it is uh
using fossil fuels we need to get to
that situation quite rapidly without
with the agriculture land-based
agriculture and I think we can we need
to Finance the agricultural transition
we need to create conditions where it's
more profitable to farm the way we do
than it is to form in an extractive way
that means the application of the
polluter pays principle it needs Banks
insurance companies food companies and
retailers yes and also governments to
enter into a new collaborative scheme
whereby we I would say it take it would
take about a third increase in Farmer's
income from where sustainable farmers
are at the moment to make all Farmers
think okay I'll go on this transition
journey and society as a whole has to
put that together and of course the
criticism which is on the Today program
this morning is food prices will go up
well I'm sure you'll agree with this
George we currently have dishonest food
prices because the polluter isn't paying
we've got hidden costs of food which are
going into climate change damaging
Public Health polluting Rivers yes the
wire is an absolute disgrace and all
those Mega dairy farms should be banned
immediately so government can play a
role and as we saw during the recent
Ukraine conflict when Energy prices went
up the chancellor stepped in and he gave
us all money to make sure that we didn't
get into energy poverty we need to do
the same with food if that becomes
necessary so it's a great Coalition of
different people including small farmers
and then right up to the big food
companies operating together in an
unprecedented way because basically
we've got no choice unless we get our
foods and farming systems in harmony
with nature not causing climate change
not threatening the six Extinction we
will not have a habitable planet
the thing is that I'm you know all that
is great but if we were to reduce meat
eating to the point at which it was in
any way compatible with a habitable
planet you know which means a tiny tiny
proportion of the amount of animal
products that we eat today it really
would be the case that only the rich
would eat it because it would become
honestly that's not true ability now
well how could it not be true I mean
I think you're I think I'm a bit older
than you but I'm old enough to remember
during the 50s and 60s when I was a boy
we had chicken once a month it was a
very expensive treat we celebrated it
and that was right because ecologically
a ton of grain is very expensive to
produce we didn't have industrial
production then and so the staple meat
was grass-fed and mainly grass-fed leaf
and lamb we need to go forward to that
situation again and it will be it will
be its true price we shouldn't fool
ourselves and the food prices
only the world's richer people could eat
it now you look back to your childhood
and say well you know we weren't that
rich you probably by comparison to the
global average you were probably
extremely rich
you're a farmers you know how how would
you not be rich by comparison
to you here which feeds into this which
is from an anonymous attendee but it
says eating well as a vegan is actually
a challenge for time poor people how can
we vegans avoid unhealthy
ultra-processed expensive food which
contains additives preservatives and
high levels of salt and sugar while
maintaining a nutritious and wholesome
food-based diet this is absolutely true
um and I don't deny that at all because
at the moment
um the products are really poor either
you need to have enough time and the
cooking skills and the kitchen and the
pots and pans to produce your own food
um in which case you can make really
great vegan meals or you're going to be
paying a lot of money for not very good
products and that needs massively to
improve and this is one of the reasons
why I'm so enthusiastic about this
unicellular one cell Revolution because
it can produce much more cheaply with
much less processing much less need to
sort of strip out all the plant
secondary metabolites in order to make
something more like an animal product
and and you can you know I mean that
that pancake I ate came straight out of
the vat the flower just it was just this
golden colored flower coming straight
out of the vat 100 bacteria we had to
mix it with a bit of wheat flour to
bring down the protein and and fat
content otherwise we would have made an
omelette instead
um it didn't require any processing you
know but plant-based products require a
lot of processing because they're so
dissimilar to animal-based products and
the the protein content is much lower
um they they they're tangled up with all
these plant secondary compounds which
are defensive compounds there's loads of
unicellular organisms which don't have
any in there so and and ultimately this
is going to be decided on price you know
we these debates are great we can use
moral suasion that's not what's going to
sway most people it's going to be are we
can we produce a really healthy cheaper
product with a far lower environmental
impact which people are going to want to
eat and at the moment it has to be said
most plant-based products have failed to
do that but what about the lab mixed
products can do much better
we're not talking about lab meat here
we're not talking about cultured meat
that's the dead Precision protein
Precision fermentation yeah
yeah
well look I'm going to condition
fermentation in the rumors of the cows
and making cheese and it's working and
it's produced it's building soil carbon
and it's coexisting with an abundance of
biodiversity what's wrong massive at a
massive land cost and so it's it's a
huge issue which is always
you asked me a question you asked me a
question let me answer it
um you know you were talking about the
polluter phase principle which I'm very
much in favor of you're quite right it's
absolutely essential but you know
included in that has got to be this
crucial environmental metric how much
land are you using and what are the
opportunity costs of that land use what
ecosystems would that land be supporting
how much carbon would those ecosystems
be absorbing if you weren't using it in
this very extensive agricultural
sprawling way using a lot of land to
produce not very much and and if we were
to incorporate those costs your system
wouldn't come out nearly as well as you
like to imagine it would so George can I
just ask you one other issue um which is
who would be looking after your land if
you rewildered it and you know across
Britain who would own it now would it be
owned by large landowners which at the
moment is the people who are wild intend
to be the people with the money yeah so
there's there's two models there's two
sort of major models of rewilding at the
moment one is I call it aristocratic
rewilding which I'm not so keen on the
other is community rewilding like the
Langan Moore trust which had bought
their own land the communities bought it
or trees for life which has brought land
through public subscription
um I mean it's you know it doesn't
necessarily change the land holding
model and in fact you can we're in a
great position to create a a just
transition here because there would be
no extensive livestock production at all
in this country if it weren't for public
subsidies you know we're paying the
money which keeps those animals on the
land and prevents a wild ecosystems from
from being restored it's completely
perverse but we could pay the same money
um two farmers to say do the opposite
you know and let you know we'll pay you
to bring back the wild ecosystems to
re-wiggle the rivers to do all the
things which which draw down Carbon on a
vast scale and have a much richer
ecosystem defending our bigger life
support systems which keep everything
going
but I suggest with Patrick you probably
feel that you are feeding the country
that that's part of your purpose it's
it's looking after the land but also
feeling that you're giving something to
the country isn't it that's what farmers
do feel
yes I feel that I think the farm a
healthy Farm is an ecosystem healthy
ecosystem we have one here it's not
unique but I feel so sure deeply sure
that if George if you came and had a
look around this Farm today you would be
blown away by the beauty of it by the
fact that we are working the land in
harmony with nature we're producing a
surprising amount of food 30 or 40 tons
of cheese a year lots of milk and meat
as I mentioned earlier and we are doing
this it's not a sprawling operation it's
it's actually quite efficient but at the
same time there's this amazing
atmosphere of nature which permeates
just about every corner of the farm and
I just think I don't want I don't want
to trade stats with you George I care
about science but I'd like you to come
here and I think we should we should
film ourselves going around and have a
positive conversation because I think
that for as long as you and I argue
about these things we're not going to
move forward to where we both agree we
need to be which is Humanity living in
harmony with the natural world and I
believe we can do it based on the
principles we've used here for for five
decades well uh thank you Patrick I mean
next time I'm in your part of the world
I'd love to come I'm always visiting
Farms um I I'm always learning from them
um I love doing so but we also have to
see the bigger picture we have to look
at the numbers because what you have to
see is what you're not seeing in any one
place that's what we mean when we talk
about ecological opportunity costs it's
like you know we're seeing what is here
and it can appeal to the eye very much
so because it chimes with those
palmyard storybooks it chimes with the
Pastoral poetry it chimes with the Old
Testament and with the New Testament
with all that thousands of years of
imagery but what we're not seeing which
very often are the things which have
been demonized by our culture the wolf
the links the deep dark forest all those
things also to an ecologist to the eye
of an ecologist have a tremendous beauty
of their own and so we can trade
Aesthetics but that actually doesn't
take us very far we also have to be
aware of what the science is saying and
of what the numbers are saying we'll
have to wrap up there and I think we're
going to ask people to vote again and
see whether anyone has changed their
mind so if you could all vote now you
have a couple of minutes and while you
are voting so we can see
what the um answer is it says host and
panelists cannot vote
um I'll ask you just a couple of final
questions really just summing up
um
George do you think this is going to
happen in your lifetime at all or is it
actually
uh just a pipe dream and and do you feel
when you look at it do you think Britain
would look more beautiful in the
traditional sense would it look
completely different under your system
so
um more beautiful than what I mean we're
facing you know we are facing a sixth
great Extinction you know we're we're
facing the collapse of Earth Systems and
it's very hard to imagine what that
looks like
um you can see it in the Rocks when it's
happened before you know and you're
talking about you know just ecosystems
disappearing soil disappearing in global
circulation systems stopping the planet
simply becoming uninhabitable and that
will include Britain if we don't make
very very drastic and rapid changes so
you know I'm deeply fearful for the
future if things do remain the same if
we do follow these sort of trajectories
of well let's just carry on a bit as we
are and tweak it a little bit and and
have a bit more livestock and a bit more
of this we have to make huge drastic
changes just as we do in energy just as
we do in every aspect of the economy or
we're not going to get through this
Century now my lifetime won't extend
very much further into this Century I
turned 60 recently you know um but you
know even now we're beginning to see
drastic impacts and a lot of those far
more than we know are being driven by
our diet and that is primarily driven by
our our eating of animals Patrick how
would you sum up just to try and
convince people to have Farms like yours
well it's so much I agree with about
what George just said and I came here 50
years ago as a back to the Lander from
London it was a hippie commune and after
50 years I'm deeply convinced that the
system of food production that we've
developed here could be applied
nationally that's our feeding Britain
report but also as appropriate to every
country in the world and I think that
there is a growing awareness amongst
especially young people that this change
is possible that it is needed and that
I'm convinced it's going to happen so I
don't feel pessimistic and the main
reason I don't feel pessimistic is from
my own practical experience here on this
Farm I think there's huge cause for
optimism and I just want to embrace
George I don't want to fight him I just
don't think we need this sort of
combative exchanges I I don't really
feel I've even done Justice if I
absolutely honest during this exchange I
just know some deep place inside myself
that this change can happen and if we if
we collaborate and talk to each other in
a new spirit I think we can make it
happen quite quickly thank you both very
much and we have got now the final vote
which is 31 now agree and 53 disagree so
um I would say that uh it's the
undecideds that have really changed so
you have swung a few people George as
has Patrick I think we only have 16
undecided so both of you have been
fantastic persuasive and you both I
think your views are so much better than
what we have now but I think either
option uh to me is just so measurably uh
more impressive than anything we're
seeing or we're seeing out of defra so
thank you both very much
um and I do hope that Georgie goes to
the farm and look at Patrick's Farm uh
Patrick comes eats one of all um
pancakes at some stage
um
good luck with that all right thank you
all very much and thank you very much
for joining and thank you so much for
all the questions which were fascinating
um and for the voting which shows that
more people are gradually being
persuaded to go vegan